last time I was here mm-hmm um I told
you that I would bring you a present yes
you did actually I forgot about that but
by priests are reminded me that last
time you were here you said I'll bring
you a present next time it was because I
was the first guest
there was a commercial break and I had
never been the first guest before so I
was like what do we do now and you guys
are so nice to me but you did say this
is where you're supposed to have
presents so I say all kinds I brought
you something did you bring it yeah they
they put this out here in commercial
break but I do not have any idea what it
is okay I wrapped this myself I have
this all my life yeah that's beautiful
look at that that's so you wrap this I
wrapped it and this is really for me I
guess you get to keep it
oh wow thank you so much my mom got me
this same present for my birthday
what's it and I thought if anybody
should have toast
it looks like their face it's a Sookie
toaster
[Applause]
it's the first toaster I've ever had
that says internet access required easy
as I thought it was gonna be I thought
it would be really fun to like have it
already and then have toast with your
face on it it would be amazing yeah yeah
well you have to take a picture you have
to mail it in and you get a thing back
in the mail and I thought you took a
picture and like it plug I think us bit
forward to the toaster and then you got
that mail it in this is [ __ ] I will
not read if tit this comes from you I'm
crazy about you so I am keeping this but
every time I mail my piece of toast to
this company in Ohio and wait for it to
come back I'm gonna be really pissed off
that's what a great idea you know that
the next literally in six months they're
gonna have the one where you take a
picture and then the toast pops out in
your faces yeah or anything else you
want to take a picture of you know
what's gonna you know that yeah that's
right we're Andy's mind when I could see
dick toast
thank you that is very you your birthday
is coming up this weekend yeah and this
I don't know how to move on from dick
toes well you just do you know you made
some coffee shops out there they can
feature dick toasts yeah
why go to Starbucks when you can have
dict oh my god this is going very badly
I love dick pics but I am I have a
gluten allergy Kristen and now she's
deciding never to come back on this show